in the last video we first thought about
the externalities the negative
externalities of having plastic bags
around it causes litter it might damage
animals in the environment in some way
and we're assuming and we assumed in
that video that we were able to
calculate the actual external cost of a
plastic bag this two cents a bag is the
impact on litter in the environment and
then we were able to figure out that if
we factor this in instead of just having
the regular marginal cost curve of the
suppliers if we added that marginal cost
curve to the external cost we would get
a supplier plus external cost marginal
cost curve and then we get what is
actually the optimal price and quantity
of plastic bags so that we actually do
not eat into our surplus by creating all
of this negative surplus where the total
cost of the bags are higher than the
total benefit but one thing that we did
not touch on in that video is how does
this actually happen if we didn't if if
we just let things be and we just had
the suppliers marginal cost curve and we
have the the consumers demand curve and
in this case the consumers were the
supermarket's then the equilibrium price
that'll be reached will be right over
here
because this the although we're
theoretically saying that there's this
cost over here the cost won't won't
won't be factored in into the markets so
if you are the benevolent emperor in
this society what do you do what do you
do to make to get the quantity closer to
this point right over here then what the
equilibrium quantity will be when you
don't factor in the external costs and
there's a bunch of options here you
could just ban plastic bags than plastic
bags you could put a quota on plastic
bags you could put a quota quota so
saying that more than a certain amount
of bags cannot be produced or you could
tax plastic bags or you could tax
plastic bags and let's think about which
of these will result in the most surplus
the most benefit to society in aggregate
and one core assumption we're going to
make is that this is an accurate this is
an accurate assessment of the external
cost per bag
so if you were to just ban plastic bags
is this benevolent Emperor
maybe seemingly or hopefully benevolent
Emperor of this society right here if
you just banned plastic bags what would
happen well then this market just won't
exist and all of this surplus that could
have existed won't exist anymore so you
would actually be destroying surplus now
you could say no no no plastic bags are
horrible they should just be outright
banned there's no amount of benefit for
which plastic bags are are worth using
but in that case you're actually arguing
this point right over here
you'd be arguing that no it's not two
cents a bag it's ten cents a bag of
negative externality and because of that
then you would have this curve shift up
even more and then there's no positive
quantity there and then maybe a band
would be alright but if the two cents is
the externality the negative externality
and if you were to ban plastic bags then
you would actually be removing you would
be removing this surplus from society so
that doesn't seem like a like a good
option now what about a quota a quota
you kind of look at the study right over
here and you say look the optimal the
optimal amount of plastic bags is 1.9
million bags per week so I will just say
that that's the most that the market can
produce but when you say that that's
assuming that you really do understand
what this demand curve looks like I just
drew a straight line here just out of
simplicity assuming you really do
understand what this marginal cost curve
looks like and throughout this playlist
we've been assuming that we kind of do
understand those things but in real in
the real world it's actually very hard
to know exactly what the marginal cost
look curve looks like and it's also hard
to know exactly what the marginal
benefit curve or the demand curve looks
like especially because they're always
changing there's always more competitors
less competitors more substitute
products more R&D things are getting
more efficient less efficient and so
it's very hard to know what the true
equilibrium quantity should be so a
quota a quota is difficult you don't
have quite the right information a tax
is interesting because the tax says look
regardless of what the marginal cost
curve really is we're just going to
shift it up by 2 cents we saw that when
we first talked about taxes and in when
we first talked about taxes we talked
about hey they're introducing a
deadweight
because you're not producing as much
quantity as you would otherwise or as
much quantity isn't being consumed but
here a tax could actually prevent a
deadweight loss because if you have a
two cent tax essentially essentially
adding the cost of the negative
externality in the form of a tax on top
of the suppliers cost right over here
you are going to cause the equilibrium
quantity to be the quantity where you're
not generating all of this negative
surplus and it's just a positive side
effect and once again this is all
assuming that this is the right number
but it would be a positive side effect
then you would also generate some
revenue for the government and what's
good about the tax in this circumstance
right over here you're not assuming
anything about what the marginal cost
curve looks like or what demand curve
looks like if as long as you're assuming
that this is the right number the tax
will always shift them whatever the
marginal cost curve is it'll always
shift it at the right point to it to
intersect intersect wherever the demand
curve is at this equilibrium point that
gives us an equilibrium price in an
equilibrium quantity so if this is the
right number and you put a two cent tax
per bag a two cent tax per bag then you
this is probably going to be the best
option in terms of optimizing the total
surplus